Speaker 1: Republican Congressman Clay Higgins,
who describes himself as being for law and order,
appears to have committed criminal battery on
video attacking an activist. Take a look at this,
media reports House Republican Manhandles
protester, who tells him, Get off me,
you're hurting me. Clay Higgins physically
removed a protester from a press conference
with Paul Gosar and Lauren Boebert on Wednesday as
the man screamed, Get off me, you're hurting me.
Several recordings showed Democratic socialist
protester Jake Burdette being pushed by Higgins
out of the DC event. As the congressman
said, you're out. We have the video. Lawyers
have reviewed this and have said to me they
believe this is criminal battery. Take a look.
Speaker 2: I know you're out,
You're out. You're out. You're out.
Speaker 1: What are you.
Speaker 9: Hoping to get out
of this list that you.
Speaker 2: Played.
Speaker 3: In the.
Speaker 1: U.S. Congress when.
Speaker 9: You came into office?
Speaker 1: So for people just listening,
what we have seen and are still watching here
is Congressman Clay Higgins, a radical lunatic
Republican, grabbing this individual, forcing him
out and away in a sort of bear hug shove. And I
mean, listen, if you if you're really about law
and order, that's a crime. It's battery and it's
criminal when it's done with the intent to harm.
Okay. Unclear. Injure. Not really clear. Annoy?
Absolutely. Or offend another person without
their consent. Jake Burdette clearly did not
consent to being manhandled in that way. When we
talk about criminal battery, it doesn't matter if
it's light or it's severe in terms of the contact.
If it's unlawful and offensive and meets those
requirements, then it is indeed criminal battery.
If you spit on someone after an argument or
something like that, even if they're not injured,
if they did not consent to that, then it's a form
of criminal battery and it's usually a misdemeanor
punishable by up to six months in jail or a fine.
States have different degrees and classifications
of battery. You can have aggravated battery,
sexual battery, family violence, battery,
etc.. But if you are for law and order,
you can only see that and say that was a crime
committed by the Republic and Clay Higgins. Now
Mehdi Hasan had a good tweet about this where
he said If a Democratic member of Congress, if a
squad member did this to a conservative protester,
it would be 24 seven on Fox News for days. And
that's absolutely right. Imagine for a second.
Okay. Just imagine for a second if AOC had done
this to some conservative protester. Imagine that
it was a female protester, right? To two women,
it would be 24 seven on Fox News. So I'm
not confident that Clay Higgins is going
to be held accountable for that, but certainly not
indicative of law and order. That's for damn sure